Tenemos estas dos moléculas aquí: propano a
la izquierda y acetaldehído aquí a la derecha,
ya hemos calculado sus masas molares y vemos
que tienen masas molares muy cercanas. Entonces,
según lo que tenemos frente a nosotros,
¿cuál de éstas creen que tenga un punto
de ebullición más alto, una muestra de propano
puro o una muestra de acetaldehído puro? Pausen
el video y piensen en esto. Muy bien.
En videos anteriores, cuando hablamos
de puntos de ebullición y por qué podrían ser
diferentes, hablamos de fuerzas intermoleculares,
porque podrán imaginar que, si tenemos un
montón de moléculas, digamos en estado líquido,
el punto de ebullición dependerá de la cantidad
de energía que necesitamos poner en el sistema
para que se superen las fuerzas intermoleculares
y las moléculas puedan liberarse y entrar en un
estado gaseoso. Entonces, cuando pensamos en cuál
podría tener un punto de ebullición más alto,
realmente sólo tenemos que pensar en cuál tendría
las fuerzas intermoleculares más altas. Ahora,
en un video anterior hablamos sobre las fuerzas
de dispersión de London, que podemos ver como
dipolos aleatorios que se forman en una molécula
y que luego pueden inducir dipolos en una molécula
vecina, y luego el extremo positivo temporal de
una podría ser atraído por el extremo negativo
temporal de otra y viceversa; y todo ese fenómeno
puede generar un efecto dominó. Y mencionamos que
existirían más de esas fuerzas de dispersión de
London cuanto más polarizado le sea la molécula,
lo que está relacionado con el tamaño de la
nube de electrones que tenga, lo que a su vez se
relaciona con su masa molar. Y cuando observamos
estas dos moléculas ambas tienen masas molares
casi idénticas, por lo tanto, podríamos esperar
que tengan puntos de ebullición casi idénticos.
Pero resulta que ese no es el caso. El punto de
ebullición del propano es -42.1°C, mientras que
el punto de ebullición del acetaldehído es de
20.1°C. ¿Qué hace la diferencia?, ¿por qué el
acetaldehído tiene un punto de ebullición tan
alto?, ¿por qué se necesita más energía para
que las moléculas del acetaldehído líquido puedan
liberarse unas de otras para superar sus fuerzas
intermoleculares? Bueno, pueden imaginar que la
respuesta es que hay otras cosas en juego además
de las fuerzas de dispersión de London. Y de lo
que vamos a hablar en este video es sobre las
fuerzas dipolo-dipolo; ya pueden imaginar hacia
dónde va esto. En el video sobre las fuerzas de
dispersión de London hablamos acerca de un dipolo
temporal que induce a otro dipolo en una molécula
vecina y luego se atraen entre sí. Ahora vamos
a hablar sobre dipolos permanentes. Entonces,
cuando observamos estas dos moléculas, ¿cuál creen
que tiene un dipolo permanente más fuerte o cuál
tiene un momento dipolar más grande? Recuerden
que los momentos dipolares moleculares son sólo
la suma vectorial de todos los momentos dipolares
de los enlaces individuales, y todos los momentos
dipolares son proporcionales a las diferencias en
la electronegatividad. Cuando miramos el propano,
aquí a la izquierda, el carbono es un poco más
electronegativo que el hidrógeno, pero no mucho
más, por lo que tendrá estos momentos dipolares
en cada uno de los enlaces que podrían verse así,
entonces tendríamos estas cosas que se ven así.
Si esto no les resulta familiar, los invito a
que revisen los videos sobre momentos dipolares.
Pero como pueden ver, también hay una simetría
para el propano. Entonces, si tomamos todas estas
flechas que estoy dibujando, si las sumamos todas
y las unimos, no obtendremos mucho de un momento
dipolar molecular, obtendremos un poco de uno,
pero en su mayor parte se cancelan. ¿Y qué hay
del acetaldehído? Bueno, tenemos varias pistas
en el acetaldehído, una es que es una molécula
asimétrica, y las moléculas asimétricas son buenos
candidatos a tener un momento dipolar más alto.
Otra pista es que tenemos un personaje aquí que es
bastante electronegativo, en este caso el oxígeno
es bastante electronegativo, y aún más importante
es más electronegativo que el carbono. Entonces,
justo aquí, en este doble enlace carbono-oxígeno,
vamos a tener un momento dipolar bastante
significativo, sólo en este doble enlace
que podría verse así, y todos los otros momentos
dipolares, para todos los otros enlaces, no van
a cancelar este gran enlace, de hecho podrían
aumentar un poco debido a la asimetría de la
molécula y así netamente toda la molécula tendrá
un momento dipolar bastante significativo. Se verá
más o menos así, y sólo voy a aproximarlo, pero
vamos a apuntar hacia el extremo más negativo,
apuntando hacia el extremo más negativo. Y pondré
esta pequeña cruz aquí en el extremo más positivo.
Y entonces esperaríamos una carga negativa
parcial en ese extremo y una carga positiva
parcial en este extremo. ¿Y qué va a pasar si está
al lado de otro acetaldehído? Bueno, el extremo
parcialmente negativo de un acetaldehído será
atraído hacia el extremo parcialmente positivo de
otro acetaldehído. Y esto es a lo que se refiere
la gente cuando habla de fuerzas dipolo-dipolo,
estamos hablando de un dipolo permanente
atraído por otro dipolo permanente,
y así el acetaldehído está experimentando eso,
además de las fuerzas de dispersión de London,
por lo que tiene un punto de ebullición más alto.
Ahora, algunos de ustedes se preguntarán "Oye,
¿puede un dipolo permanente inducir un dipolo en
una molécula vecina y que luego se atraigan entre
sí?" Y la respuesta es simple es sí, tiene mucho
sentido. Sin duda podemos tener un dipolo y luego
una interacción dipolo inducida, y podríamos
cubrir eso en algunos ejemplos en el futuro,
pero esto también puede ocurrir: podemos tener
un dipolo temporal que induce un dipolo en el
vecino y que luego se atraigan entre sí, lo que
puede tener un pequeño efecto dominó; y podemos
tener un dipolo permanente interactuando con otro
dipolo permanente y que sean atraídos entre sí,
y podríamos tener un dipolo permanente que
induzca un dipolo en una molécula vecina.